وهذا مسائل عربيه ياخذكم الى كواليس مسلسل
عمله نادره لقاده حصريه مع ابطال العمل في
اخر يوم تصوير الزميله راندا بولعزم
تسحبنا وتصحبنا في موقع التصوير له
[موسيقى]
مسعود اللي خايف على والد اخوه
وبيتهمني بشرفي
هو اللي قتل بلال
اكتر حاجه كنت قلقانه منها اللغه الصعيدي
بس ما عدا مصحح لغه استاذ عبد النبي
بصراحه طمنا كلنا كلنا يمكن ناس كتير كانت
قلقانه لان في ناس اشتغلت صعيدي قبل كده
طبعا جمال سليمان اشتغل قبل كده
بس احنا معظم الناس ما اشتغلناش الحقيقه
فكنا قلقانين بس هو طمنا بصراحه وكان
بيشتغل معنا طول الوقت اول العمل يجمعك مع
زوجك هشام لا اشتغلنا مع بعض فلوس قليله
لسه هينزل على ام بي سي
بس هنا يعني تقريبا
مش شغالين مع بعض
بس بتبقوا ما فيش مشاهد بتجمعكم لكن في
مشهد واحد بس لكن هي الخطين مختلفين خالص
هو بيتين مختلفين بيت حسن ابو عصايه وبيت
عبد الجبار قولي لي بقى يعني كانيلي وهشام
عشان تشتغلوا في لوكيشن واحد وتيجوا
المشوار المرهق ده كل يوم
قربكم من بعض بعادكم عن بعض جدا لان احنا
بنشتغل في اوقات غير كل واحد بيشتغل في
اوقات غير الثاني هاتي اداؤه كان لك
كومنتس كان ليكي اي ملاحظات على اداءه ولا
كنت بتبعدي قلتي لا انا مش مليش دعوه يعني
بصي انا دايما يعني لو يعني انا وهو
بنتفرج مع بعض
يعني مش انا اللي اقول الكومنت بصراحه
يعني عنده مخرج يقول لكم طب هو بيسالك
يقول لك ايه رايك
اه بيسالني يعني اه بقول له حقيقي وهو
عامل دور حلو جدا وهو دوره صعب دوره من
الشخصيه اللي هي متعلمه وبعد كده بيدخل
مع والده اللي هو حسن ابو عصايه برضو
العادات والتقاليد
عمي عبد الجبار عوضهم ودفع لهم اكتر من
تمنها والموضوع خلص ازاي بتقيم عملك مع
نيللي مع مراتك موقف اللي احنا فيه ده
يعرفك يعني لو اي اتنين متجوزين عايزين
يعرفوا بيحبوا بعض ولا لا ده يشتغلوا مع
بعض يعني لان انت لو ما بتحبش البني ادم
اللي معاك ده تزهق منه انت بتشوفه كل يوم
في الشغل وتشوفوا هنا وبتشوفوا هنا فالحمد
لله يعني ده ثاني ثالث اختبار وبالتالي ان
احنا يعني انا ببقى مبسوط لما بشوفها
يا حبيبتي يعني
شباب حاجه رباني يعني انا بيتهيا لي قبل
ما تبدا المسلسل الصعيدي انا كنت شاكك في
الصعيدي بتاعها بنسبه 80%
انا كنت احنا ما كناش خايفين عليا كنا
خايفين عليها اول ما الكاميرا قالت اكشن
بتتحول تتحول يا عظيمه يعني ايه عظيمه
بصراحه
اجلب الحلال
مش احسن لك من الهباب اللي بتعمله احيانا
بنقعد لحد ثاني يوم يعني نحن الحد الادنى
ليوم العمل التصوير الحد الادنى الادنى 12
ساعه النجاح كله بيتكلم
بيتحرج النجع باللي فيه شو اللي بيغير
العادات والتقاليد اللي بغير العادات
والتقاليد هو الحقيقه اشياء كثيره راس
الفن لانه الفن بيقنع الناس
بالابعاد السلبيه لاي تقليد او عرف الناس
عايشين عليه بورجيهم الجانب
الظالم الاعراف والتقاليد في متابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات